Now things will become even more complicated.
I'm going to give you a list of numbers
slightly different than the one from before--
those are actually floating numbers. They have a decimal point.
And I want you to implement the function variance.
It takes our data and returns a single number,
which is the variance of the data.
So for the data set I will be giving you,
it so turns out that the variance is 62.572.
Now some hints.
First you're going to use the function mean,
that you have already programmed, so it's in your code. Just use it.
And then the trick that I want to play is:
We have our list here inside the function data.
We're going to transform this into a new list called "ndata."
It is the normalized data, which effectively is the data minus the mean,
which I'll call "mu."
So you compute the mean, called it "mu," perhaps,
and then subtract from the data--from each data item--the mu.
And this subtraction is not entirely trivial to make the new data set.
The commands I have been using is
I iteratively construct with a for loop the data set.
First I set it to an empty list.
Then there's this function called "append"--"dot-append,"
and whatever's inside the function--you've got to figure this out--
will be appended to this list over here.
So with an initial assignment of an empty list and a for loop,
we'll go through all the data items
and I'll append the appropriate thing to this new data.I get out this new data list.
Then I can apply the same mean function to the new data list,
and that gives me the variance. You got it?
If not, listen to the video again.
So here's the coding environment.
Our data set.
I've given you the function mean that we've programmed before,
and now you are to program the function variance.
So if you print variance of data set,
you get the desired 62.572884.